[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في ولايه لانا اوديل هذه في الفلبين
ومراضي تعتبر مدينه اسلاميه
وهي من المدن اقدم المدن
التي تسكنها
عدد كبير من المسلمين بالفلبين
وهذه المدينه غنيه عن الثقافه والتقاليد
الاسلاميه
وتتنور هذه المدينه بعلمائها
والذين يتخرجون او تخرجوا من البلدان
العرب
فانا افتخر بهذه المدينه التي كبرت فيها
وكان والدي كذلك من من هذه المدينه ولد في
هذه المدينه
وتلمذت في احدى المدارس
من هذه المدينه
واسم هذه المدرسه مدرسه ابن سينا
المتكامله
فمن هذه المدرسه
تحصلت على
اساس العلم
الاسلامي
لانها مدرسه اسلاميه تدرس فيها المواد
الدينيه
رغم ان هناك مدارس
مسيحيه ما زالت هناك مدارس مسيحيه لكن هذه
من المدارس التي تتفوق في في علم الدين
علم الدينيه
فمن هنا تعلمت اسس التحدث بالعربيه
وقراءه القران
وغيرها من المواد الاسلاميه
والخلفيه في تعلم بالعربيه اني
تعرضت في بيئه
تعليميه لان والدي كلاهما
مدرستان مدرسان
فوالدي
كان
يبذلان جهدهما لتقويم سلوك
ابنائهم
نحن الاخوان كنا
نتعلم
العربيه منذ صغرنا في البيت لان
امنا تعلمنا
كيف نقرا القران وكيف نقرا
العربيه ونتحدث بالعربيه لان هذه كانت من
الاشياء التي تهمهما كثيرا يعني ان يربون
اطفالهم في بيئه مسلمه مع علمهم ان ان هذا
هذه الفتره او هذا الزمان يعني زمن
زمن اصبح فيها الناس
لا يرغبون كثيرا في علم الدين
بل
نجد كثيرا من الناس الذين تاثروا بالعلوم
الغربيه
تاثروا بالتقاليد الغريبه الغربيه غير
مسلمه
فلذلك اهتموا كثيرا في تقويم سلوكنا حتى
نكون مسلما مثاليا
لنكون
قوادا لمجتمعنا الاسلامي خاصه في الفلبين
او في مدينه مراضي
فالقصه بدات لما كنت اتصاحب مع
الاصدقاء الذين يحضرون حلقه القران
فلم اكن يعني لم اكن ارغب كثيرا في تلاوه
القران لكن هناك فتره
احضروني الى حلقه القران
وقدموه الى قدموني الى استاذهم
وتعرفت معه حتى انه امرني ان اجلس معهم
اقضي وقتا بسيطا لان اجلس معهم
واتدارس معهم في القران فلما سمع قراءتي
اصبح
يريد ان ان يعرف المزيد عني يعني عن خلفيه
اين تعلمت
فمن حينئذ قال لي لابد ان تحضر يوميا يعني
في كل جلسه الحلقات لازم ان
احضر مع هذه الاصحاب
من ذلك الوقت من ذلك الفتره لحظات يعني
ذهبيه
بدات
امتني او
بدات ارغب في معرفه
القران على عمقها
والتعلم
بقراءه القران قران على دقتها
بدات احضر هذه الحلقات
تحت مدرسه صغيره
نفر قليله من من الطلاب
حتى بلغت ادرس عنده القران عند الاستاذ
جابر
لمده خمسه شهور فبعد بعد انتهاء الخمسه
شهور
قال لي اريدك ان
تخبر ابويك بانك سوف تتخرج
يعني مع هؤلاء الذين
انهوا حفظ جزئين يعني المقرر كان عندهم
جزئين فاريدك ان تخبر والديك انك لازم ان
تاتي في يوم كذا وكذا تحضر معك والديك
وتاخذ معك
الجلباب يعني هناك حفلات تخرج للقران
فاخبرت بذلك ابويه ففتحجبه لانهما لم
يعلمان اني احضر هذه الحلقات القرانيه
فمن تلقاء ذلك الوقت
يعني
رايت من من وجههما السرور
وشعرت التاثر يعني من من سلوكهما بعدما
عرف اني مع هؤلاء الطلاب يعني الذين
يقراون القران
فرحوا جدا وقال لي والدي يعني لم يتوقع
ان انني
كنت احضر هذه الحلقات القران
فمن ذلك
هناك
مقابلات
قامت بها هيئه التعليم هيئه التحفيظ
القران الكريم العالميه في احدى المدارس
اسمها التضامن وكانت الموظفه احدى الموظفه
من تلك المدرسه
تعرف امي فقالت لها لو عندك طالب بعمر 12
ممكن ان تاخذها معك وتجلس للمقابله
لمواصله الدراسه في ماليزيا
فخلاصه يعني فبالاختصار انا قبلت من هذا
الامتحان والحمد لله سافرت هنا وذلك في
السنه 2007
في كيلانتان هذه منطقه ولايه كيلاندان
فهناك
تلقيت مع مشايخ
سبحان الله هؤلاء مشايخ
رائعون
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يسالك الناس عن الساعه
قل
انما علمها عند الله
وما يدريك لعل الساعه تكون قريبا
ان الله لعن الكافرين
واعد لهم سعيرا
خالدين فيها
[موسيقى]
ابدا لا يجدون وليا
وصيرا
يوم تقلب وجوههم في النار يقولون يا ليتنا
اطعن الله
واطعن الرسولا
وقالوا ربنا
[موسيقى]
ان
كبرى انا
فاضلون السبيلا
ربنا
ضعفين من العذاب والعنهم لعنا كبيرا
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تكونوا كالذين
اذوا موسى
فبراهم الله منا قالوا
وكان
عند الله وجيها
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا س
ديدا يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله
ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
انا عرضنا الامانه على السماوات والارض
والج
بال
فابين
ان يحملنها واشفقن منها وحملها الانسان
انه كان ظلوما جهولا
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التحق القارئ محمد نجيب عبد الجليل
بالجامعه الاسلاميه العالميه في ماليزيا
لمواصله دراسته الجامعيه وللتعميق معارفه
بالقران الكريم وعلومه وهو الى ذلك يتولى
امامه الطلاب في مسجد الحرم الجامعي ويامل
العوده الى مدينته مراويه بعد التخرج
لتحفيظ القران الكريم لابناء موطنه
انا قد شاركت
بمسابقات القرانيه
التي
قامت بها
مدرسه منزل وهذه هذه المعهد او المدرسه
تقع في استراليا
وهذا كان في سنه 2019
عبره اون لاين لان هذه كانت فتره
فلم استطع ان احضر هناك
فقالوا نعمل هذه
المسابقات
من خلال او عبر الانترنت
فالحمد لله
من الله علي ان اكون او ان افوز بالمركز
الاول
وهذه كانت تلاوه
تلاوه القران
وتجويده وكذلك المسابقه الثانيه التي
شاركت فيها كانت مسابقه من احدى المعاهد
في الفلبين جديدا في سنه هذه السنه قبل
اربعه اشهر مسابقه تلاوه تلاوه القران
ايضا وتجويده كذلك
ولله الحمد
حصلت ايضا على مركز
اولا في الفلبين
مهما انها
بلاد او بلد مسيحي
لكن عندما تذهب الى المناطق
التي تسكنها المسلمين
ستجده هناك معاهد
ومدارس قرانيه
يدرس فيه القران
ويدرس فيها التجويد لان
الاناس في الفلبين
يهتمون كثيرا بالقران الكريم
يعني من ملاحظه
ان الناس في الفلبين المسلمين خاصه
يقدسون
ويقدسون القران حق التقديسا لانهم يعلمون
ان
العزه والشرفه
والمنزله الرفيعه والرفعه
في القران
ويحترمون كثيرا ويشرفون حمله القران
الطلاب القران وحفاظ كتاب الله تعالى
القارئ الذي كنت استمع اليه كثيرا
هو الشيخ المشاري العفاسي
كنت استمع واكرر
كثيرا قراءته
ويعني مسجلاته في القران
وحتى يعني
جعلتها في في هاتفي واستمع اليها عند
عندما نامي
وعند فترات الدراسيه
لاني اريد ان ان اتقن قراءه
واتعلم بعض بعض الاحكام من خلال قراءته
واعرف ان هناك من القراء الذين يتلون كتاب
الله تلاوه
ممتازه ورائعه ولكن
اميل الى قراءته
استمع الى الشيخ عبد الباسط لكن الله صوته
صوت البلبل
ودائما احاول ان ان
اقرا مثل واحاكيه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اذا وقعت الواقعه
ليس
لوقعتها كاذبه
خافضه
الرافعة اذا
رجت الارض رجا
وبست الجبال بسا
فكانت
هباء منبثا
[موسيقى]
وكنتم
ازواجا ثلاثه
فاصحاب الميمنه
[موسيقى]
ما اصحاب الميمنه
واصحاب المشامه
ما حابوا المشامه
والسابقون السابقون
[موسيقى]
اولئك
المقربون
في
جنات النع
يم
صدق الله العظيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]